if they raised it maybe they sold 50 of
the business for a million bucks i mean
if it's
if it's worth 2 million i'm throwing up
i went to the vault and i got these
puppies out
hottest watch in the world i was looking
at it oh i was staring at this
is a daytona rainbow so how rare is that
like like you'll never see another one
are you serious
today we're here we're going to give
kevin some some business pitches
with valuations all right there's one of
them on here
yeah that uh i'm really looking forward
to
seeing getting the reaction yeah yeah
this is gonna be a good one
the business is a real estate franchise
play they allow dog owners in malls and
strip centers across the country
to drop off their dog for a few hours
any location they raised a million
dollars in their pre-seed round
what's their valuation at do you think
it's a joke that you can't raise a
million dollars for a doggie daycare
center
it's just it's like a dry cleaner's
worth more than that
that's ridiculous it's freezing okay i'm
very offended
well i don't think it's even worth a
million bucks what do you think they
raised what do you think
i mean if they raised it maybe they sold
50
of the business for a million bucks i
mean if it's if it's worth 2 million i'm
throwing up
9 million [ __ ]
i knew it how are you ever gonna get
your money back you're gonna have to
steal every dog
that's ridiculous the first ever
delicious vegan cookie dough
you can be eating raw or baked into a
cookie they raise one million in their
seed around what's their evaluation
we see these kind of things on shark
think all the time you know low sugar
low salt healthier choices vegan i get
right it's hard to make something taste
good that's cookie dough vegan
there there's this this actually has a
chance to be something they raised a
million bucks
yeah i say they did it at a four million
pre
uh i'm gonna say i'm gonna go five
i'm gonna go with six on the money you
also knew the answer
i didn't remember six six pre-mud
you know it's not crazy okay well you
know that that product's gonna be binder
either it's gonna go through the roof
through the moon because there's a lot
of people that want health
crazies this company is an ai powered
meme generator
you can create edit distribute extremely
dynamic names that are the funniest and
most relevant
thing each instagram means giphy there
is 16 million in their seed round
what do you think their valuation is
okay we know memes are hot yup
smoking hot and they've stayed smoking
hot memes you know they can be kind of
hard to create
yeah they're doing it with ai yeah i say
this thing's at 50 million free
i'm going to go with i'll say 45 million
60. double that no way
no way 120 million you know i said i
said it was gonna
yeah i said it was 120. i get it that
somebody would step
up for that because if this works it's
going to be
cute this real deal
he missed the one over here you know
what i'm talking about coconut water
mixed with triple distilled vodka
fantastic idea
coca is available in 27 states in the
u.s
and four provinces in canada including
the lcbo in ontario
everything they sell in the us is
proudly made in new york city
everything in canada made in waterloo
ontario
low carb low sugar gluten free oh yeah
baby
it's summertime try it out
it has to stay wound all the time and
the only way to do that is use a robot
to do it
otherwise if it falls behind you're
gonna spend like a year
trying to catch up it's like paul
newman's daytona sold for 17 million
dollars
because it became part of who he was it
was seen in all his movies it was on his
wrist all the time and so
it became part of his iconic being and
so when you start collecting watches
they become yours
and for me that means red bands for
televisions
wardrobe's a big deal i'm gonna shoot
television they want consistency they
want continuity
so i go back season four and i've got a
bunch of watches different colored bands
and she said to me where's the red van i
said what do you mean
she said no no black suit white shirt
red band you know you're mr wonderful
you wear red band i went you got to be
kidding she said no i'm not kidding
go get a red man from that year on if
you look at shark tank episodes
red banding everything i went to the
vault and i got these puppies out
the all-time classic all right you start
with
is a steel white face daytona everybody
in the world wants one of these
it's not an expensive watch it sells for
about twelve thousand dollars i know
that's dough
but the minute you walk out the store
it's worth 35 000.
now the way that watch looks today
into modern times right
it looks like this so they don't have
just stealing where they got the ceramic
black very cool right but look at the
heritage look at that right so what is
the the unit get a little get a little
size this is
this is the watch that paul newman races
for car racing
so that's why it has the units yeah so
you're timing the lap the one lap of the
racing car here's a brand
that is up and coming to australian guys
avanti
you want to talk about a crazy looking
watch yeah no kitty
get this solid that is a solid piece of
sapphire
solid piece of sapphire look how cool
that looks on your wrist i mean you're
making a big statement with this puppy
oh yeah ah so maybe maybe the skeleton
is it called like a skeleton fate or
just a skeleton well it's also oversized
this is over 40 millimeters this is
really you're
that is a daytona rainbow so
how rare is that like maybe like you'll
never see another one
are you serious i'm just joking with you
see what's going on here these are all
diamonds but four degrees of separation
on the color
you know how hard that is to do to find
those stones and make them all the same
and
insert them into that watch that's
factory these are investments
yeah i was going to say these are great
investors yeah yeah there's millions of
dollars of watches here but this is up
from 125 when i bought it to 440 000 if
i wanted to sell it
i i think when i looked at every single
one of these watches that would have
been like the one watching yeah
you thought that was crazy look at this
this is called
eye of the tiger it's also a daytona
just like those but what does that look
like
it's like an eye of a tiger it's
encrusted insane
so you know i need these watches because
i want to look like trash in miami
let me show you another crazy watch this
is called fp
journey it's the blue and it means blue
dialed
but it's beautiful because it can be
black it can be blue
this watch is what putin wears
and it became famous when they saw him
this is the rumor about this watch
this watch used to cost 15 17 000 as
soon as putin was
seen wearing it boom 37 000.
here's one story watch only 30 of these
in the world okay this is an iwc pilot
watch very very famous style
beautiful right yeah that boat blew up
in
beirut two years ago watch companies
said we're going to create 30 of these
with the
back the cedar of lebanon this tree on
the back
one of 30. that collector i told you
about
earlier knew that my mother was lebanese
and said kevin
you're aware of this watch i said yeah
but how am i going to get where there
won't be one in north america
ever and he petitioned the ceo of this
company
because i was half lebanese to let me
have one wow what i found out later
he gifted me his he gave it to me as a
gift
all right i was the only one in america
when people see this they go
nuts that know this brand you've never
seen a dial like this and you never will
again
it's all about the dial
take a close look at that look at how
it's sparkling oh oh
my god that one's sick it's very sick
initially the market didn't really dig
it and then about
three months into it and people started
wearing them they really got into it
they only made 100 of these
i have one of the hundred they've since
redesigned it again
but the rarity and also if you look
sideways at that dial look at how crazy
that is see what's going on there
by the way all these are coming into my
coffin with me when i die because i'm
going to need them in the after world
or else how are you going to tell the
time it's a statement piece right
you think that's made out of sapphire it
is a solid block of sapphire
this is like probably just the most
sleek looking like clean watch
yeah known all around the world that
took off in italy back
in the 60s and 70s and every girlfriend
wanted that watch what they would do is
they'd take out a few links from their
boyfriend's watch
and lose the links so that they couldn't
wear it back
if you flip a watch they'll never sell
you another one right because
it's going back to the respect of the
art and no you went there asking a favor
to be sold watch at retail because you
respect the art respect the
brand and then you turn around and sell
it to make 15 grand
you're cut off for life so like this i
can go swimming with yeah you leave that
on your wrist all right
yeah that's it they still make some of
the most accurate movements in the world
but grand seiko is a fantastic starter
watch six or seven
thousand really high quality immensely
beautiful
the polishing on the steel is crazy it's
just it's
it's perfect my go-to watch in miami uh
when i'm walking around is definitely
the rainbow because it's just
total trash i love it it's totally gosh
it's just totally blinged out and it's
so miami and
right tonight if i hit car bones or
something i'll be
wearing this watch and everyone's just
gonna freak out they're gonna freak out
if you like that video where do you see
my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe